you're about to see the correct way to
conduct a strip or visual search first
the initial verbal command is important
it makes a difference
be professional all right Jones come
with me for strip search next conduct
the search in private if possible pick
up for clothing please this is a most
vulnerable moment you've just asked
someone to undress in front of you
proper courteous verbal commands are
essentially okay put your head back full
cleave look in your nose
capsules containers and even small
hacksaw blades have been found in the
nasal passages open your mouth okay
stick your tongue up okay stick it out
okay lower your lower lip pull it out
lower down good okay the upper lip
remember a calm professional attitude is
important keep in mind you're ordering a
naked person to obey you spread your
legs little wider
okay okay lift your penis way please
testicles if he's uncircumcised ask him
to pull back the foreskin be
professional and alert let's turn around
look at the neck back spinal area and
buttocks
okay bend for for me please and spud
your buttocks look for anything inserted
you may see a thin string indicating
something is there remember
do not deviate from what is appropriate
and professional a female is searched
the same way as a male with two
exceptions I need you to take your
earrings off any bands any bobby pins
clips out of your hair and take your
clothes off the first is to remove all
clips hair ornaments bands or hair
pieces these should be carefully
searched the second exception is the
female breast area now I need you to
lift your breasts
okay you can drop them in summary for
correct strip-searched procedure
remember that your initial verbal
command makes a difference be
professional be systematic stay alert
you